Hello, everybody! My name is Markiplier, and welcome back to Resident Evil 7.
Now, the sounds you're hearing are the sounds of war.
apparently. And war that I need to fight for some reason
I don't know
What is going on in Jack's head now that he's a horrible monstrosity, but you know he was kind of a horrible. whoa Hey hey
hey, hey, hey hey, I could really use a bomb at this point, but I don't have the means ow well ow
I don't do. I have the means no. I don't I'm just gonna go run for it. You know
I don't have the space to fight right now, so I'm just gonna and I go over here
Got this medicine go into the woods here circle around. Okay. What's going on over here where am I going now?
What the hell oh hi oh?
oh
*gasp*
*chuckles*
yes
Yes, it's a super hitting fist
ready for use
*laughs*
Of course you know of course left good old good old the hittie ah
Hitties been upgraded to punchy now. I got punchy and fistie here
Haboski *laughs*
Right'on your dick right'on your dick
this is the greatest thing ive ever seen in my life
This is the greatest thing
let me charge it up
Woah! Woah! Fisty is- Fisty is raring to go!
boom
Alright well that
god..god damn
god
damn
oh, man. I think I should aptly named my new lefty into fisty again because fisty
fisty seems to have another purpose.
*laughs*
I mean, I don't want to call a spade a spade, but that vibration. That's very intense.
Habooski!
*laughing*
jus-just
I'm laughing not at that. I'm laughing at the music. About how the music's like fricking like Avengers music- da da da!
Your fist is unbelievably powerful Joe!
Wow okay you're already thinking about putting them down not like you know rescue him or try to save him or something
Something like that. No Jackie boys just got to go you know what it's fine. I get it I get it
I remember this area this was a
Marguerite's house area oh
oh..That's sad
ooooh
Zoe made this I didn't I didn't see this before ah that's sweet, okay, well
okay Well, that's sad
Jesus man this game is so hilarious
And I know you know that the developer knows that it's hilarious
The developer knows it like it's it's also obviously just like the music
I think proves it because the music that's his way to hype and to do royalty-free sounding to not be like a a
conscious choice of ridiculousness
Alright, oh no. I can't get through. Oh it's already open. Okay, alright then
stupid puzzles
Always causing a ruckus. Oh hey, I'm
Eating Marguerite's bugs. This is- I guess, gross- very gross. Yeah, wait
boom
Okay alright then can you you can stop any time now. Oh, geez.
Alright
oh, yeah, oh yeah, that's a good stuff. Who wants some? Hi! Hello.
What happens if I do a partial [charge]? Oh, still good.
Oh, oh oh
oh Boy, I love this. you're still alive?! what I guess it wasn't a full charge might as well
Just have been a normal punch at that point. I guess oh come on. I want to go those ways
Now why didn't they just burn all this down whoa?
charging
Stomp right in your leg stomp right in your ass stomp right in your face
Hey friend
Whap I?
I love it
why can't I go through there? I even see the doorway down there. Oh come on
Alright fine. y'all hype bastards. Let's see what you got
Come on. I'm ready for ya. Oh big guy alright wait hang on. I got a sunburn you want me to come to you alright
not today
Oh, he's dea- oh, he's dead. Oh, he's very dead
You think the combos still work now, I mean not that anything's gonna survive long. Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah champion effigy. Oh god
I love this fist ah
Called super fisty all right. Woah, yeah, this is lovely man
It's been a while but since I've been over to the Baker residence. Just just a little bit just a little while you know
He's gotta be! Gotta be up ahead. Okay. Well alright then
Hello
uh-oh
somebody got rekt
Hello
Hello, or maybe maybe Joe has been infected like the whole time, too
Maybe I I honestly don't know. I don't know how he could just not know about all this
That's weird
Okay, I'll go there eventually
Do you have to ask Joe do you have to ask?
Alright, lost inventory has been moved to the item box. Okay. That's weird
oh! That's right when I went down the river. I guess I got- lost all my shit. my bombs!
My bombs, please oh boy here we go
All my effigies oh yes
gimme gimme gimme gimme
okay, alright, so
I
need to maaaaake
I can't make anything except chem fluid, but I don't need more of that or
Goop juice, but I can't do anything more
[Reading] We finished analyzing the tissue samples believed to be from Jack Baker. The cells exhibited extraordinary
Resilience to physical and chemical damage; the e-series muta my seed secretes a telomerase like enzyme through the cell wall causing abnormal
activision of the ERK pathway to achieve forced cell division quickly regenerating damaged tissue
However, the repeated cell division quickly leads to breakdown of the intercellular structure leading to the sloughing slurry like effect
We've observed in the collected sissue- tissue samples. Our working hypothesis puts this down to the cells reaching their Hayflick limit
Note that the samples from the other family members- the wife Marguerite, the son Lucas and daughter Zoey- do not exhibit the same extreme
Regenerative properties the symptoms may differ from subject to subject further study is required
Fancy. Oh Steve!
Steve
What are you doing to him? what are you doing to him Steve?
What are you doing to him Steve aah you carry on Steve you have a good one Steve. See you around the bend
I'm gonna save one more time because I'm crazy like that all right see ya Steve. see ya buddy
All right, you have a good one steve all right later
Later Gator all right. What do we got here? Can I go down there? No?
Man, it's been a while since Ive been back in here.
Oh
So cool I love it. I love it. I love it all right come on Jack time for a final showdown
Mmm. Well I don't know he is her father. Zoey! I guess he's just trying to take her home weird
Zoey
Hey Jack
woah! Zoey
All right
Miss me
thump
ow ow
Oh! My super punches, and I'm not even gonna do it really with super punches
Bam oh ow ow-y ow [yelps], goop juice all better
oh oh
ow
Come on
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah
Oh
Gonna punch right in ya ass, I know your weak spot Jack. come on show me dat ass
Ow
ow don't do that Jack. Don't do that Jack come on, come on. Don't be like that Jack
woah. Oh, yeah, you made your first mistake uh-oh
Come on
come on, come on. oh yeah
ow
Ah goddamnit whoa duck. hahahaa! gotcha gotcha
Oh baby. Wait hang on.Wait hang on, let me see wha.. whoa whoa?
Never could never could never will
Yeah, Jack what you gonna do about it? Oh yeah jack
Oo Shit
I mean  just cuz I got a super-fist don't mean I'm cheating
Come on. Agh, meant to duck. Aw  meant to duck
Come on, come on, come on, come on gotcha on the ropes now.
Oooh look me in the eye jack
oh-oh oh-oh
Okay
Oooh *laughs* oh
Ho Shit
hey Zoey. Zoey, I got caught up in my rage
You ah? you dead. Oh, you not there. Okay. You are not there
All right well didn't even need this xrail Zoey! Zoey!? you all right put on some clothes damn it
There you go, Zoey! Zoey why are you naked Zoey?
Oh now Joes' all scared
She's still covered in goop. I guess that's a better alternative
She would be naked if that goop went away and nobody nobody wants that
uh-Oh
BLAP BLAP right in your neck just like *stutters* z-that z-that feel.. painful
who is it.. Mr Umbrella?
Is Ethan!
Well, I mean he did kind of throw you to the wolves first off the bat, but hey, it's a happy ending yeah
Alright, now. I know I know I know this is the end here, and this is awesome. I love this DLC
This was so fun like just from a pure fun standpoint. It was so fun, but what I got to do
I got to see if there is like an unlimited battle arena mode with Joe because God the punching mechanic is so fun
punches thrown
620. ah it's so fun. extreme challenges complete all t-to obtain the spirit blade!
*laughs*
wh-at *laugh* what?!
Challenging details can be found in the stats from the pause menu
Joe must..yes! Oh that's just a difficulty. Ah shit, weapon AMG-78a
M21 shotgun
We gotta go Joe must die
oh
Cassette tapes are required autosave frequency has been reduced
Oh hell yeah. Hang on. I'm not gonna do a full playthrough the game again, but...all right come on skip
This movie skip skip skip skip. I just got to get oh
Oh hi
What are you doing here?
ow
Whew this is, this is a difficult whoa they get up quick now
There we go boom okay, alright well then that was difficult okay hang on everybody hold on hold on to your hats, Oh a throwing knife
Wait
Wha-? throwing knife when the hell did...?
Wha-? what has it always been there?  Did i, did i not get the
Wha-?..Oh
Wow what the hell this is this has changed dramatically I need a cassette tape to save
Wow okay all right
Ah! Nooo
Noooo
No *laughs*
oh nooo
There we go oh yeah, oh the ticky ticky bommie wah me boxes okay, all right well
Well if that's the way you're gonna do it then I am
NOT gonna play your game
OH Boy yeah Wow okay, they weren't joking about this this is this is gonna be difficult
Uh-Oh, they spotted me
Wow okay that doesn't finish him off okay
Oh yeah, this is gonna be a bit more tough
oh yeah
Oh boy
OH Man that already put me on the edge
Ima die
uh Okay Wow alright so that is
Tough as shit. Man, I don't know, man I don't know oh man. Oh, wow okay? I have an idea
Whoa
Okay aim for the head actually apparently whoa just aim for the head yeah
Whoa, okay, I need to do this
Hey Raunfle stomp
Alright did I get you yeah, no yeah, I got you, okay
There we go, okay, so now I kind of gotcha okay?
So I'm gonna just press forward a little bit because this is hard as hell
Holy shit. This is hard
Uuu..Wow okay that would have been death yeah, man, they set this up definitely to screw with me
oh
Wuuwee
Uh-oh,That didn't sound good
Okay well i'ma run now
Oh No, it's no not one of those guys. I hate those guys. I don't have health for this
Haboski! Oh no!
Ah, Well there I go. okay that is freaking difficult, but that's a fun I'm not gonna keep trying with that
That's a fun mode though. I think that would be a fun challenge to do so I think that ends it for
Resident Evil's new DLC it was super super fun. I hope they come out with more stuff
I hope to see a Resident Evil aid like
There's so many cool things like the Ethan must die stuff like the Joe must die stuff like that is fun fun fun
Really really well done, and I just love it like even this not a hero that was fun
It really was this was more of the same, but this was something special End of Zoey
I love that so thank you everybody so much for watching. Let me know what you thought down the comments below and as always
I will see you in the next video
Buh-bye!
*outro music*